AstraZeneca may
be able to help.
>> Jason: HOLLYWOOD IS
HELPING TO LEAD THE CHARGE
TO DESTROY THE NATIONAL
RIFLE ASSOCIATION WHILE
GIVING BIG TIME MONEY TO THE
PROGUN CONTROL CAMPAIGN.
BUT THEY WANT TO TAKE A
STAND AGAINST VIOLENCE, THEY
MAY WANT TO LOOK AT THEIR
OWN MATERIAL.
A NEW STUDY BY THE
CONSERVATIVE PARENT
TELEVISION COUNCIL FINDS A
DR. INCREASE OF PORTRAYALS
OF VIOLENCE ON TV IN RECENT
YEARS.
ACCORDING TO THE STUDY
NEARLY 61% OF 287 BROADCAST
PRIME TIME TELEVISION
EPISODES FEATURED SOME FORM
OF VIOLENCE DURING THEIR
NOVEMBER SWEEPS PERIOD.
39% OF THOSE 287 THOSE
FEATURED GUN-RELATED
VIOLENCE.
LET'S GET REACTION FROM
ACTOR ANTONIO SABATO JR. WHO
IS ALSO RUNNING FOR
CONGRESS.
HE JOINS US NOW FROM
CALABASAS, CALIFORNIA.
WE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING HERE.
>> THANK YOU, MY FRIEND.
>> Jason: WE ARE PUTTING UP
ON THE SCREEN, YOU CAN'T SEE
IT WE ARE PUTTING UP ON THE
SCREEN A PICTURE OF GEORGE
CLOONEY.
MR. CLOONEY HAS BEEN PRETTY
AGGRESSIVE ABOUT GUNS AND
HIS BELIEF ABOUT GUN
CONTROL.
>> RIGHT.
>> Jason: DO YOU THINK
HOLLYWOOD IS PART OF THE
SOLUTION HERE OR IS
HOLLYWOOD PART OF THE
PROBLEM.
>> THEY ARE PART OF THE
THESE ARE THE SAME PEOPLE
THAT ACTUALLY BELIEVE
HILLARY CLINTON WAS GOING TO
BECOME THE PRESIDENT AND WAS
GOING TO BE A GOOD
PRESIDENT.
SHE LEFT OUR PEOPLE TO DIE
IN BENGHAZI.
LET'S NOT FORGET THAT.
THESE ARE THE SAME PEOPLE
WHO WENT TO THE ACADEMY
AWARDS PROTECTED BY LAPD,
BODY GUARDS WEARING PIECES,
GUNS ALL OVER THE PLACE AT
THE ACADEMY AWARDS AND THEN
THEY ARE MAKING MOVIES ON A
WEEKLY BASIS WITH GUNS THAT
THEY WANT TO BAN.
YOU KNOW, THE NRA HAS DONE
MORE TO PROTECT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE THAN HOLLYWOOD COULD
EVER DO LET'S TALK THE TRUTH
HERE AND MAKE SURE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE KNOW WHAT'S
GOING ON HERE.
I THINK THEY KNOW THAT
BECAUSE WE ELECTED DONALD
TRUMP.
IS HE DOING AN AMAZING JOB
AND THAT'S WHY I'M RUNNING
FOR OFFICE IN NOVEMBER.
I'M GOING TO WIN.
WE HAVE GOT TO BRING COMMON
SENSE INTO GOVERNMENT AND
OUR COMMON DAILY LIVES.
I MEAN, WE CAN'T LIVE WITH
THESE LIES EVERY SINGLE DAY.
THE MEDIA ARE SPILLING LIES,
24 HOURS A DAY.
AGAINST OUR PRESIDENT.
AGAINST THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY.
THAT'S ALL THEY DO.
AND THIS TIME THEY ARE NOT
GOING TO WIN BECAUSE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE WOKEN
UP.
WE WANT OUR AMERICA BACK AND
WE HAVE GOT TO PROTECT OUR
AMERICA AND OUR
CONSTITUTION.
>> Jason: WHAT DO YOU THINK
IS HOLLYWOOD'S
RESPONSIBILITY?
THEY ARE ENTREPRENEURS.
DO THEY JUST PROFIT IN THE
REASON THEY MAKE MOST WITH
GUNS IN IT IS BECAUSE
AMERICANS GO TO THEM AND
THEY PAY MONEY TO GO SEE
THEM.
IS IS IT THEIR
RESPONSIBILITY OR SHOULD WE
JUST CALL OUT THEIR
HYPOCRISY?
WHAT'S THE RIGHT ANSWER?
>> WELL, IF THEY WANT TO
TALK ABOUT GUN-FREE ZONES
AND ALWAYS BLAME IT ON THE
NRA.
THEY ARE THE HYPOCRITES U
LISTEN, RIGHT NOW WHY DON'T
THEY MAKE MORE MOVIES ABOUT
POSITIVE STUFF?
WHAT ABOUT FAMILY VALUES?
WHAT ABOUT GOD ONCE IN A
WHILE?
WHAT ABOUT, YOU KNOW, THE 10
COMMANDMENTS?
WHAT ABOUT GO GOOD STUFF,
POSITIVE STUFF, LOVING
CARING STUFF.
I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT THE
DISNEY MOST.
I'M TALKING ABOUT IN
GENERAL.
TV SHOWS THAT INVOLVES GOD
AND FAMILY AND SITTING DOWN
AT THE TABLE AND THINGS LIKE
THAT.
YOU KNOW, I URGE THEM TO DO
THAT.  WE GOT TO COME
TOGETHER AND TALK ABOUT THE
REAL STUFF HERE.
THE PROBLEMS ARE NOT THE
GUNS.
THE PROBLEMS ARE THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE PULLING THE TRIGGER
LIKE WHAT WE HAVE SEEN IN
FLORIDA.
AND THEN WE KEEP VOTING
THESE PEOPLE WHO ARE
SHERIFFS.
PEOPLE IN GOVERNMENT WHO
CANNOT PROTECT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
AND THIS HAPPENED IN
FLORIDA.
SO, RIGHT NOW, WE HAVE TO
EDUCATE PEOPLE AND TELL THEM
THE TRUTH.
>> Jason: DO YOU THINK, YOU
KNOW, THE BREAKDOWN OF THE
FAMILY IT SEEMS TO BE A
COMMON DENOMINATOR WITH A
LOT OF THESE KIDS.
THEY CAN'T DISTINGUISH RIGHT
FROM WRONG THERE MAY BE SOME
MENTAL INCOMPETENCY, BREAK
DOWN IN THE FAMILY.
DOES HOLLYWOOD BELIEVE IN
ANY OF THAT?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
LISTEN, WE HAVE SOME ISSUES
RIGHT NOW.
OPIOIDS EPIDEMIC.
PEOPLE ARE ADDICTED.
KIDS ARE ADDICTED TO
MEDICATION STUFF AND THAT'S
REALLY BAD.
PEOPLE ARE NOT SITTING
AROUND WITH THEIR KIDS
ANYMORE AND TALKING ABOUT
WHAT'S GOING ON IN YOUR
LIFE?
CAN I GET TO KNOW YOU?
DO YOU WANT TO GET TO KNOW
ME?
IT'S ALWAYS ABOUT COMPUTERS
AND PHONES AND THIS AND THAT
AND ALL THESE DISTRACTIONS.
WE HAD GUNS IN THIS COUNTRY
FOR 200 YEARS ALLED SUDDEN
THESE PROBLEMS HAVING EVERY
SINGLE WEEK THEY WANT TO
BRING IT ON GUNS.
LET'S BRING LOVE AND
HAPPINESS AND FAMILY VALUES
BACK INTO OUR DAILY LIVES.
>> Jason: LISTEN.
I THANK YOU.
I THINK THERE ARE A LOT OF
KIDS THROUGHOUT WHO CAN
DISTINGUISH RIGHT FROM
WRONG.
IT'S LIKE A PUDDLE OF
GASOLINE AND THEN THEY SIT
15 HOURS AND WATCH A VIDEO
GAME OR GO WATCH A VIOLENT
MOVIE AND IT'S LIKE THROWING
A MATCH ON THAT GASOLINE AND
CAN
KAN
KABOOM.
>> AND LEFT ALONE.
THESE KIDS ARE LEFT ALONE.
THERE IS NO MORE
COMMUNICATION BETWEEN THE
TEACHERS AND THE PARENTS
ANYMORE.
PARENTS CAN NOW WALK INTO A
SCHOOL AND, YOU KNOW, TALK
ABOUT THEIR ISSUES WITH THE
SCHOOL ITSELF.
ALL THESE REGULATIONS AND
THIS AND THAT.
SO, WE'RE NOT REALLY FREE
ANYMORE.
THEY WANT TO HOLD US HOSTAGE
AND, YOU KNOW, WE DON'T HAVE
BIBLES IN SCHOOL ANYMORE.
THEY WANTED TO TAKE OUR
AMERICAN ANTHEM AWAY.
WE DON'T RESPECT THE FLAG.
I'M FIGHTING FOR WHAT IS
RIGHT.
WE HAVE GOT TO FIGHT FOR THE
FLAG AND FIGHT FOR THIS
COUNTRY.
WE HAVE 26 BEAUTIFUL
AMENDMENTS.
WE HAVE GOT TO KEEP THEM
THERE.
ONE OF THEM IN THE SECOND